what happens in mainstream math
education is so much about testing
people and separating out people into
those who are good and those who are not
good and we don't really focus very much
on just the sheer appreciation of it and
I think it would be wonderful to have
math appreciation as a really conscious
part of math education and to
acknowledge that it's really important
to preserve the appreciation of math all
the way through rather than just trying
to drum facts and algorithms and
techniques into people's brains if in
the process of doing that you kill off
the appreciation because the process was
so painful then I think we've really
done a disservice to everybody and to
mathematics